Hello everybody!
We are Pongfinity
And welcome to a new episode of Challenge Pongfinity
Let's see what kind of challenges you have come up with this time!
[Play ping pong while having a staring contest]
I'm a bit scared!
First one to break eye contact loses.
I'm ready!
Let's try the Roger Federer shot of
table tennis.
That was pathetic.
I think this challenge is
perfect for me!
A lot of you who are watching have not yet subscribed to our channel
So remember to subscribe right here!
Okay so we're gonna try and
break this glass with a table tennis smash
It's not gonna break, is it?
It's going to break if Otto hits!
This is how you break a glass with a table tennis shot.
That's how you do it!
WHAT!?
It actually broke!
I never thought that it would break...
Look at that!
There we have it.
Thanks for watching!
Make sure to subscribe to our channel so you don't miss out on the next episode!
Until next time!